which are thoughts on Bitcoin
specifically Bitcoin having coming up
and kind of the macro backdrop it's
specific thoughts they're just generally
people should have it in that safe haven
pocket well I think that I think some
people would consider Bitcoin not a safe
haven they would consider it a wild
speculation I think other people would
say it's not a speculation it's a great
store of value regardless of whether
it's a great store value or pure
speculation
typically in either of those aspects the
risk return is pretty high in other
words the asymmetry of the trade is
pretty good so you know it would not
shock me at all to see Bitcoin go to
$2,000 and stay there for five years it
also wouldn't surprise me to wake up
tomorrow and find out it's $50,000 it's
I think that's the kind of potential it
has in both ways right I think it's ink
it has incredible potential but it's
that but because it has such a high
potential whether you like it or not
whether you hate it or not if the rest
of the world decides that bitcoin is the
way to go just the same way that
currently the world has decided that the
dollar is the way to go
bitcoins going to go a lot higher and
the you know so I think the asymmetry of
it warrants having at least some
exposure whether or not and I I'm to a
certain extent a Bitcoin maximalist I
think there's actually a lot of problems
with Bitcoin I don't really have time to
go into all of my reasons right now but
again because I think others will view
it as a relative safe haven and and
because I think it's a great speculation
even if it's not a safe haven I still
think I still own some I think everybody
should own some I kind of a Bitcoin
maximalist because I think it has enough
of a first mover advantage that it would
be very hard to supplant not impossible
but I think would be very hard to
supplant the networkers effects are
there the branding is there all of the
the reasons typical things that you see
around a first mover advantage Bitcoin I
think has in spades so I kind of like it
for that reason I don't know I don't
know if I'm kind of rambling there or
not I don't know if that answers your
question I did
iiiiii I think the thing that I like
about Bitcoin
and it's not quite the this way now as
it was two or three years ago I loved
that it was just the wild wild west it's
pure pure it's it's big it's coming
under more regulation but for a while it
was just pure wild wild west capitalism
just raw and some people like that and
some people didn't I found it
fascinating so and I still kind of find
it fascinating so if for no other reason
I'm gonna continue to follow a Bitcoin
for that aspect yeah one of the things
that's been very apparent I think over
the last kind of month or so in this
liquidity crisis is you know hours of
operations circuit breakers all these
things that are there to kind of temper
volatility and equities and in other
markets it doesn't exist in Bitcoin so
you get the you know 50% drops and then
the turnout and it's back 20% and you're
just like Jesus what is this and you
know hey that's a free market